hello and welcome to this video yeah and
the gun game before I gifted my 2500
rating away what a shame
with a completely idiotic game White was
basically more or less toast out of the
opening and then I made a colossal
blunder really that is hard to explain
anyway so I have to win against craft
Seuk to get some rating back came yeah
it's difficult to win against this
opening as as we all know I play that
with white
yeah he wants to go see form not not
that easy night at 5:00 I have Queen
efore in mind age six is a bit of a
debatable move maybe because this is in
one way desirable because Bishop g5 is
not the nicest pin to play against but
it also weakens Kings side a bit Knight
f5 gets more is more interesting with
age six and because the knight on f5 is
then it's tougher to expel okay so it's
just central noise
[Music]
you know I don't I don't think I have a
particular problem here
but why this of course extremely solid
let me think
what did I have what can I do like we
need six maybe and then IG for ideas
Queen is six okay then now everything is
obsolete after he played that so I'm
taking at him it's no big yeah why is
that working
I mean is an idea for an idea I thought
that would be quite quite annoying
me it looks annoying
so what is the next movie about White
Queen age form is also something you
have to be aware of here
so Queen h4 threatens maid age three I
can take on f2 twice so let's do it
the knight can maybe move maybe I should
have thought about this a little bit
more I did not calculate 95 which is a
move okay yeah here I think I can just
take him
and no f4 is detected
yeah it's just no good move
just no good move I'm not trading Queen
Sam I asked to go to f1 and now we have
to see what the best way of doing this
is probably just take me to the white
rook doesn't have red squares rook d1
probably just c3
yeah c-pawn should should win this quite
easily
can you have to Queenie one mate
[Music]
yeah it's a fully booked yeah that did
one twin downhill quite quickly I'm not
certain that c4 and taking on c6 is
right here I think this is a roughly
equal position and white should probably
just stay but the engine suggestion of
h3 is I think quite quite a good idea
just cover g4 it's it's useful we we saw
in the game that did led to problems so
I took this quince is six and now energy
form it's already traveled some yeah
whatever he does it's not not really
great this one yeah and I'm not even
certain that Queen h4 is the best yeah
Knight takes f2 is stronger this this
and then rook c8 just play this position
and this is an additional idea the
problem me it's not f5 right yeah I mean
black hair seems to be better at least
this is the initial engine evaluation
but this is just quite complicated and
not it's not a clear thing earlier there
are many trickery main many tricky ideas
this for example of threatening 97 check
King f7 h3 is a system it's murky yeah
okay h3 is immediately giving it away
96 know who should take this good takes
takes I think I'm fine on what I did was
was right yeah it's important I'm not to
exchange Queens now I mean this would be
probably a winning ending but you win
easily with Queens on the board the
white king is just so unsafe you know
was quite quite easy at the end
yeah the Bishop g4 line here this one oh
that's harsh in accuracy
this is a decent line and I recommend 92
in this position to get a game going but
just of course not
usually advantageous for whites but at
least I think you can try to play for
something okay guys thanks for watching